A Nestle nos Estados Unidos vai tirar
todos os corantes sintéticos dos
produtos até 2026. Mas e aqui no Brasil?
Pois é, veja bem, a gigante alimentícia
decidiu remover esses corantes depois de
que houve muita pressão dos consumidores
americanos. E não é para menos, né?
Esses corantes artificiais estão ligados
à hiperatividade, déficit de atenção,
alergias, irritabilidade, principalmente
crianças. Imagine o seu filho agitado,
sem conseguir se concentrar na escola. E
pode ser aquele salgadinho colorido que
ele adora. Mas olha que interessante,
nos Estados Unidos eles mudam a fórmula,
mas aqui no Brasil continuamos
consumindo esses mesmos corantes. Por
que será? E tem mais, viu? Não só os
corantes, não. Aromatizantes,
conservantes, adoçantes. Tudo isso pode
estar prejudicando a sua saúde sem você
saber. Vira o produto e lê o rótulo.